bonsoir ici gouvix un bras je fais
partie du groupe des nouveaux
romantiques distinguer adeptes du
nouveau savoir vivre qui tente veut site
de réunir les règles d'or des anciennes
bonnes manières
aujourd'hui il faut bien le dire un
petit peu poussiéreuse en les adaptant
au monde moderne et active qui demande
beaucoup plus de décontraction
cette semaine j'ai reçu une adorable
lettre d'une charmante jeune femme qui a
été invité à l'elysée et qui me demande
quel doit être son comportement
un exemple vous êtes vous défaire
l'atmosphère se détend le président fait
un bon mot alors toto dit j'étais à la
barre aux grenouilles
j'avais de l'eau jusqu'aux genoux m
systar mba est autour de 10 y'a des
passes et on ne fait pas comme cette
personne si vous êtes invités à l'elysée
grasset votre merengues dans votre
assiette avant de rire comme ceci je
raconte la bête où je raconte une rock
non une autre alors napoléon entre dans
l'auberge aujourd'hui sort g20 et
l'aubergiste répond je m'excuse et trois
chaises à la nouvelle cuisine qu'elle
volumineux courrier
beaucoup de gens m'écrivent pour me
demander la signification de certains
plats voici un petit lexique illustré
pour vous y retrouver une décoiffés avec
ses amours une frise et aux lardons
encore et puis fin une allure iguerande
folle une tête de veau ravigote à mon
bon souvenir d'une chèvre trentaine de
chavignol et pour finir une bonne volée
une purée de marrons
réveil rustique sat est tout chaud pas
c'est mon pote à moi s'excuse et c'est
fatigant c'est du direct bien le dernier
conseil de la fumée en toutes
circonstances
évitez de laisser transparaître vos
sentiments en public
cela risquerait de paraître vulgaire
merde tu peux tomber ma bidoche n'ayez
crainte sonia je vais vous les ramasser
voilà chez vous demande une seconde je
vais me laver la main voilà un garçon
très polis et surtout très courageux
maintenant je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine pour d'autres conseils au
revoir
[Musique]